the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free
to make a donation or view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
let's take a look at storyboard number
10 back in earlier sessions we talked
about the detail of glycolysis one of
the points that I emphasized is the fact
that it's necessary to maintain redox
neutrality in the cytoplasm of a
mammalian cell it's also necessary to
maintain Redux neutrality and
prokaryotic cells not just eukaryotic
cells at the glyceraldehyde 3-phosphate
dehydrogenase step of glycolysis nad
plus was consumed and converted to NADH
that means we have to find a way to
convert NADH back to nad plus in order
to make like Ollis estat continuous
process back in lectures 3 & 4 I said
that there were three ways to convert
the NADH back to nad plus these were
alcoholic fermentation in anaerobic
cells homo lactic fermentation again in
an anaerobic environment and the third
is respiration which occurs in the
presence of oxygen I'm going to loop
back now and revisit this topic I want
to spotlight three general strategies
that cells use to achieve redox
neutrality in the cytoplasm
the first is lactate dehydrogenase the
second is called the glycerol
3-phosphate shuttle and the third is
called the malate aspartate shuttle
panel a of this figure shows the
cytoplasm working in concert with the
mitochondrion you can see depicted on
the left the pathway of glycolysis in
the middle pyruvate dehydrogenase and to
the right the citric acid cycle or TCA
cycle which we just covered there were
two important boundary conditions for
the discussion we're about to have the
first is that oxaloacetate is as I've
mentioned earlier present only in very
small concentrations within the cell and
especially in the mitochondrion as a
consequence the mitochondrion too
not have a transporter to allow it to
escape in other words it's concentration
is preserved at about one micromolar
inside the mitochondrion the second
boundary condition concerns the fact
that NAD+ and NADH as well as nadp+ and
NADPH cannot go directly across the
mitochondrial membrane so in other words
there are two separate pools of this
nucleotide cofactor one in the cytoplasm
one in the mitochondrion I'll come back
to the importance of the two pools in
just a few minutes let's look first here
in panel a at the mechanism by which
lactate dehydrogenase achieves redox
neutrality in the cytoplasm we've
already covered this so this is a bit of
a review note that you see nad plus
getting converted to NADH in the
cytoplasm that's at the gap th or
glyceraldehyde 3-phosphate dehydrogenase
step the hatch lines that you see
represent the flow of electrons in other
words electrons flow from glucose and
they end up in NADH then the lactate
dehydrogenase enzyme transfers the
electrons from NADH into lactate so
these electrons from glucose are
involved in the reduction of the ketone
functionality of pyruvate into the
alcohol functionality of lactate and
that's where the electrons stay the
other product of this reaction as you'll
see is nad plus which is now available
to enable the oxidation of the next
molecule of glucose what happens to the
lactate that's produced in a working
muscle cell that lactate will escape
from the cell go into the blood and then
go to the liver or another organ that's
capable of doing the pathway of
gluconeogenesis as I've mentioned in the
past gluconeogenesis is a pathway by
which non carbohydrate precursors such
as lactate are built back up into
glucose keep that working muscle
scenario in mind because I'm going to
come back to it later when I talk about
physiological responses to stress such
as what I'll call the fight and flight
scenario that's all I'm going to say for
now about the LDH shuttle that is
lactate dehydrogenase
shuttle in panel a which is the first of
the three pathways by which redox
neutrality is maintained in the
cytoplasm the second pathway to retain
Redux neutrality is the glycerol
3-phosphate shuttle this pathway is
particularly active in the brain and in
skeletal muscle once again follow the
hatched lines to follow the path of
electrons as they go from glucose and
ultimately in this case they're going to
end up being deposited into oxygen to
form water starting at the top you see
nad plus being reduced to NADH at the
glyceraldehyde 3-phosphate dehydrogenase
step gap th next we're going to
temporarily borrow a molecule of
dihydroxyacetone phosphate DHAP DHAP is
a ketone and what we're going to do is
deposit the electrons from NADH into the
ketone functionality to make the alcohol
glycerol 3-phosphate the source of the
electrons was NADH and now you've
accomplished your chemical goal which
was to restore the nad Plus pool to the
cytoplasm but we borrowed a molecule of
dihydroxyacetone phosphate and we've
somehow got to get that back let me
point out at this point that the
reduction of DHAP to glycerol
3-phosphate was accomplished by the
cytoplasmic form of the enzyme lists are
all three phosphate dehydrogenase which
catalyze step 2 on the story board we're
going to deal more with coins mq in the
next lecture but for now it's a molecule
specifically a quinone that's easily
reduced to its hydroquinone form called
qh2
the structures of q and q h 2 are shown
in the box q h2 is in the mitochondrial
membrane in glycerol 3-phosphate
dehydrogenase the mitochondrial version
of it is present in the outer part of
the mitochondrial inner membrane like
nadh and fadh2 q h to the hydroquinone
is what i've called a mobile electron
carrier q h2 is going to allow the
electrons that started out in glucose or
an NADH of the gap D H step to flow
through the electron transport chain
which we'll come to in the next lecture
flow into oxygen which is reduced to
form water this terminal reduction is
shown in step 5
effectively in the glycerol 3-phosphate
shuttle we're using oxygen in order to
oxidize NADH back to nad plus and once
again maintaining a constant supply of
nad plus is necessary in order to make
glycolysis a continuous process panels
see shows a third strategy for
maintaining redox neutrality in the
cytoplasm this is called the malate
aspartate shuttle and this pathway is
operative in heart liver and kidney to
the left we see the production of NADH
just as we did in the previous two small
pathways at step one let's assume that
there's a molecule of oxaloacetate
present as part of the cytoplasmic pool
of organic acids oxaloacetate ROA is a
ketone in the cytoplasmic form of the
enzyme malate dehydrogenase working in
the reverse direction from the one that
we see operative in the TCA cycle is
able to reduce the oxaloacetate to
malate we just reduced a ketone oay to
an alcohol malate in step three the
accumulating malate is transported by a
malate transporter into the
mitochondrial matrix which is of course
the location of the TCA cycle at this
point we're going to be using one of the
steps of the TCA cycle specifically
we're going to use malate dehydrogenase
the mitochondrial version of the enzyme
this time to convert malate to
oxaloacetate that reaction is an
oxidation we use the mitochondrial pool
of nad plus to carry out that oxidation
in effect we're using the electrons that
came in for malate to reduce NAD+ to
NADH in the mitochondrion now take a
careful look at step four looking to the
left you see the hatched lines go all
the way back to glucose which was the
source of the electrons to the right the
hatched nut lines by step five go to the
electron transport chain all the way to
oxygen we haven't done the electron
transport chain is yet so you're just
going to have to trust me for
while there's an enzyme nadh
dehydrogenase in the mitochondrial inner
membrane that will take the electrons
from nadh and eventually regenerate the
nad plus in the mitochondrial matrix in
step 5 we're taking the electrons from
the NADH produced by malate
dehydrogenase and entering those
electrons into the electron transport
chain then in a manner that's quite
similar to what we did in the previous
shuttle the glycerol 3-phosphate shuttle
those electrons are going to be
transferred to oxygen to make water
before I go on let's review a little bit
between step 1 and step 2 in the
cytoplasm we deposited electrons into
oxaloacetate to make malate that step
restored nad plus levels in the
cytoplasm which is what we wanted to
accomplish however we've consumed a
molecule of oxaloacetate and as I've
mentioned before the cell has to try to
preserve the concentration of this very
precious molecule we now have to find a
way to restore oxaloacetate that we
borrowed in step 1 now let's look back
at the step 4 where malate was converted
to oxaloacetate in the mitochondrial
matrix because the molecule of malate
came from the cytoplasm this is a net
increase in the mitochondrial matrix of
one unit of malate and ultimately one
unit of oxaloacetate we need to find a
way to get that molecule of oxaloacetate
back out into the cytoplasm in order to
make this shuttle a continuous one in
the cofactor section of 507 Joanne
taught us about the ways that pyridoxal
phosphate and pyridoxamine work in order
to put amino groups into organic acids
such as oxaloacetate and that's what's
going to happen in this case
oxaloacetate is converted into its amino
acid homolog aspartic acid why did we do
this
emanation reaction well there is no way
to get oxaloacetate directly out of the
mitochondrion because there's no
transporter for it but there is a good
transporter the aspartate transporter
that will take aspartic acid out into
the
plasm so the oxaloacetate is converted
temporarily into aspartic acid in the
mitochondrion and that aspartic acid
then slips out through its transporter
to the cytoplasm once in the cytoplasm
there's a similar pyridoxal mediated
mechanism to deaminate the aspartate to
regenerate the cytoplasmic molecule of
oxaloacetate that we borrowed at step
one a few minutes ago in panel D I
summarized that we've looked at three
different small pathways that enable the
cytoplasm of the cell to always have
enough nad plus to oxidize glucose to
pyruvate these pathways are first the
lactate dehydrogenase system second the
glycerol 3-phosphate shuttle and third
the malate aspartate shuttle